moving on
our main story tonight concerns
something that's been getting more and
more urgent over the past two months lea
michelle's come back it's an unpleasant
surprise and the longer we let it
continue the harder it'll be to stop
sorry did i say lee michelle's come back
i meant monkey pox monkey pox has come
as an unpleasant surprise and it's
becoming increasingly hard to stop for
the past several months you may have
noticed monkey pox being discussed with
an increasing sense of alarm there are
now dozens of confirmed cases of monkey
box in the united states hundreds of
confirmed monkey pox cases in the u.s
u.s cases skyrocket from 1400 less than
two weeks ago to nearly 3 000 today the
cdc now reporting more than 4 600 cases
more than 5 200 cases reported more than
6 300 cases now reported currently the
u.s leads the world in case count over 7
000 it's true monkey box cases are
rising sharply and that is the absolute
worst collection of words that you're
going to hear this summer aside from
maybe 50 year old dane cook engaged a
long time 23 year old girlfriend
although that's not actually fair it's
not that big of an age difference
they're just an entire timothy chalamet
apart
math is fun
but the spread of monkey pox is
genuinely alarming its most obvious
symptom is skin lesions which can in
severe cases be extremely painful and
while the pain is not remotely funny
people have been getting very creative
in how they describe it
i had between six and 800 lesions it was
like someone taking like a a whole
puncher all over my body um right under
my skin it's like somebody takes a dull
knife that is searingly hot and is
cutting inside of you and then uses a
toothbrush afterwards and brushes it
anytime it grazes something or touches
something it literally feels like
someone's taking a potato peeler to your
skin it's like sitting on shards of
glass
and i hope that's pg-rated enough
that sounds really bad and this is not
remotely the point but sitting on shots
of glass while not entirely graphic
isn't exactly pg either if you took your
kids to see minions rise of grew and the
first 10 minutes was the yellow thumbs
popping their asses on shards of glass
you'd race your kids out of the theater
immediately
sadly as with kovid there is a lot of
misinformation flying around right now
online there are theories like monkey
pox can be caused by the covid vaccine
which it can't and did it escape from a
lab which it didn't it seems a spreading
virus yet again is bringing out the
worst in people including targeting
those suspected of carrying it take this
tick tock video of a woman on the subway
with an image of a monkey and a question
mark clearly implying she had monkey pox
it got over two million views and when
the woman in question found out this is
how she responded
hi uh i'm the girl from the video in
which you are watching is me sitting on
the train talking on the phone the skin
conditioner i have is called ns1 and the
bumps that you see are tumors
the tumors are benign but they are still
all over my skin and give me a lot of
health complications both physical and
mental you know i've come a long way and
i like me
you know i'm not that healed and i'm not
above being vengeful
yeah
five thousand middle fingers to the dumb
[ __ ] that thought taking an unsolicited
video of a complete stranger and
stigmatizing them for a medical
condition was a good idea that is
clearly not what tick-tock is for
tick-tock is for discovering you've been
opening freezer pops wrong your entire
life yeah you just snap it in the middle
no scissors necessary my whole life has
been a lie
frustratingly despite the fact we're
still in the middle of the coveted
pandemic we seem to be replicating some
of its key mistakes from persecuting
strangers to spreading misinformation to
badly mismanaging the public health
response so tonight we thought it'd be
worth talking about monkey pox what it
is how we fumbled our response to it and
what we should do going forward let's
start with the basics here monkeypox is
a pox virus it's part of the same family
that causes smallpox so thankfully it's
not nearly as transmissible or as fatal
it usually presents in humans with fever
swollen lymph nodes exhaustion headache
and a rash though it can also cause
complications like blindness if the
lesions reach your eyes and in rare
cases can result in death now quick note
on the name despite being called monkey
pox it didn't actually originate in
monkeys it was first discovered in 1958
in monkeys in denmark but they likely
got it from rodents who are thought to
be the main carriers in fact it's
endemic in rodents in central and west
africa where they've been sporadic
outbreaks for decades now and it's
actually been transmitted between people
continuously in nigeria for at least
five years
interestingly the u.s even had its own
monkey pox outbreak nearly 20 years ago
which came about thanks to an unexpected
culprit
health officials are investigating what
appears to be another case of an animal
virus that has jumped to human beings
it's called monkey pox and it may be
linked to pet prairie dogs in the
midwest the midwestern prairie dog is
not a common pet but some pet stores
have been selling them along with other
exotic animals from around the world
and that say investigators is why 30
people today are suspected of having a
disease that has never been seen before
in this country okay i have one main
question and it's this why the [ __ ]
would anyone want to own a prairie dog
and you know me i have an abounding love
for the rodent community guinea pigs
excellent hamsters perfect capybara big
pensive sweetie but
it's going to be a hard pass for me on
this little plague ridden freddy krueger
look at those [ __ ] hands
also quick shout out to the absolute
[ __ ] that came up with that name pull
one out for the stupidest friend of
laura ingalls wilder who saw an animal
that is generously a big hamster that
[ __ ] a meerkat with garden brakes for
hands and went dog and it somehow stuck
now thankfully we managed to contain
that particular outbreak and put a stop
to the sale of prairie dogs before
person-to-person contact could begin but
now things are clearly different and
look there is still a lot we don't know
and information that we do have is still
very much subject to change but as it
stands as of this taping the vast
majority of cases have been among gay
and bisexual men and their sexual
networks the virus spreads through
sustained skin to skin contact and it's
currently believed to be spreading most
commonly during sex though in rarer
cases it can spread through respiratory
droplets during prolonged face-to-face
contact or through bedding or towels
used by someone with monkey pox and the
thing is
not long ago there was an expectation
that this outbreak might be containable
at the end of may when there were
roughly 130 confirmed cases outside of
africa one who official said this
this outbreak can still be contained and
it is the objective of the world world
health organization and member states uh
to contain this outbreak and to stop it
yeah that sounded pretty reassuring did
they and i for one want to believe the
words of the head of the smallpox
secretariat which is a very impressive
sounding job while also sounding like
the most depressing movie sequel of all
time
and to be fair that optimism wasn't
unwarranted there were many reasons to
think that we could and indeed should
quickly get this under control first
because monkeypox has been around for a
while we are at least somewhat familiar
with it also because it's similar to
smallpox there is good reason to believe
that the tools we already have to fight
that work on monkey pox too so this was
not like the early days of covid when we
didn't know anything about anything
remember march 2020 we were lysoling our
groceries like they came out of the
sewer geraldo was on tv claiming you
could test for covid by holding your
breath and we did a show on the corona
boris on march 1 2020 in which the main
advice that we gave our full unmasked
studio audience was to wash their hands
i even did a little dance about it and
while i was clearly wrong about covid i
was right about those moves i look like
julia stiles in save the last dance very
white and unnecessarily hyped up by the
crowd
but with monkey pox we were in the
fortunate position of having
pre-existing tests vaccines and
treatments unfortunately the rollout of
each of them has been painfully flawed
and let's start with tests
testing for monkey pox was initially
siloed within the cdc and its network of
public health labs of which there are
around 70. people also had to meet
certain eligibility criteria to qualify
for testing making the whole process
slow and cumbersome and slow and
cumbersome are the last words you want
to hear in the early days of a disease
outbreak apart from of course the
opening lines of imagine sung a cappella
as of early june we were only conducting
10 tests per day in total across the
country increasing to just 60 by the end
of the month now thankfully testing has
ramped up since then with the body
administration finally allowing
commercial labs to test as well but
barriers still very much remain for one
thing there is only one fda authorized
test which requires you to swab lesions
and aside from being painful that means
you have to wait until they appear to
even run a test and they may not be the
first symptom so until we develop and
vet new forms of tests like ones that
can be used on saliva or with throat
swabs our results are going to lag but
what's more we ridiculously don't have a
good system for gathering and sharing
data monkeypox was spreading for more
than two months before states were even
required to share data with the cdc
making tracking cases across the country
incredibly difficult and the truth is
even communication within states can be
absurdly antiquated
you know i talked to officials in
missouri and florida who were counting
monkey pox cases via facts i think we
all in the united states kind of expect
public health to work like amazon prime
you know we're going to get our packages
in two days and everything will be fixed
but unfortunately you know public health
in this country has been underfunded for
decades okay first the only way we think
public health is like amazon prime is
that they both force people to pee in
plastic containers
but second
fax machines the only thing fax machines
should be used for nowadays is for
ending the sentence hey remember fax
machines and that is it
so we didn't know where the cases were
or how many there were and whatever
numbers that we did have were likely
drastic undercounts because we weren't
testing enough which is already very bad
then there's the vaccines where again we
should have been in pretty good shape
the us government's actually been
developing and stockpiling new smallpox
vaccines since 911 when there were fears
that it would be used as a bio weapon
just watch this segment from 2002 which
features a familiar face
the us government began stockpiling
smallpox vaccine last year and has
placed orders for tens of millions more
doses we have enough material that if we
needed to god forbid a catastrophe of a
massive attack we would be able to have
a vaccine for everyone in the country
yeah there he is anthony fauci the
forest gump of catastrophic contagion
but the point is the government very
smartly built up massive reserves of
smallpox vaccine it is just one of the
one ways that the war on terror made us
safer but unfortunately
those huge stockpiles weren't available
at the start of this monkey box outbreak
thanks to a number of key strategic
errors for a start incredibly we let 20
million doses expire
we just
did that
which seems especially unconscionable
given as i mentioned earlier multiple
african countries have had outbreaks of
monkey pox for decades now and might
have appreciated a shot or two
sharing vaccines would have served two
purposes basic human decency but also
abject selfishness in that stopping
outbreaks over there might well have
prevented the current outbreak over here
and yet for some reason we let the
vaccine sit unused on a shelf in our
reserves like an expired chobani or
a 90 million movie on hbo max by the way
hi there new business daddy seems like
you're doing a really great job
i do get the vague sense that you're
burning down my network for the
insurance money but i'm sure that
that'll all pass
so
at long time
we had more than 20 million vaccines
available but when this outbreak began
we were down to just 2 400 usable doses
which is enough to fully vaccinate just
1200 people now we did have 300 000
doses sitting in a warehouse in denmark
but for some reason officials waited
weeks as the virus spread before finally
deciding to ship them to the us and that
sequence of bad decisions is why we've
been seeing scenes like these
hundreds lined up for the monkey pox
vaccine last week at this clinic in
manhattan but supplies quickly ran out i
came here for like a few days already
because i don't have an appointment i
went to the website and the
the website crash been trying to get a
vaccine for the last almost two and a
half three weeks tried at multiple
vaccine centers and everyone's out of
vaccines so here i am exactly vaccines
are apparently the beyonce concert
tickets of healthcare announced with
little warning gone in 30 minutes and
will likely have you screaming you won't
break my soul at the top of your [ __ ]
lungs
so tests hampered by red tape vaccines
expired by the millions and finally
there's treatments remember monkey pox
can be incredibly painful and there is a
drug that shows promise in reducing
those symptoms but it too is way harder
to get than it should be an experimental
drug that could help some people who
have monkey pox is available but the
question is can they get it the
medication is called techaviramad brand
name teapox there's no shortage of
teapots but it's only fda approved for
smallpox for monkeypox it's still
considered an investigational drug the
cdc has lifted some requirements so
doctors can prescribe it under something
called expanded access but that involves
hours of forms and extra appointments
yeah and even if you found a doctor
willing to do all of that some patients
are then finding themselves waiting days
for the shipments of the drug to arrive
from the strategic national stockpile
which just isn't great considering
remember that this can feel like sitting
on shards of glass it is not a condition
that you can just put off dealing with
for a few days like a cold or a uti if
you're super tired
basically
every part of our early response to this
made things harder than they needed to
be and i will say there have been some
improvements recently we've seen some
progress on testing more vaccines are
finally coming with large numbers set to
start arriving in october and the
paperwork for teapots has been
streamlined somewhat so if you think you
need any of those you should still
absolutely be seeking them out but the
delays we've seen in fixing these
problems have been absolutely maddening
and it has been hard not to wonder
whether the lack of urgency has had
anything to do with who's been getting
hit the hardest
you know this is obviously spreading
uh it's something that warrants concern
what i don't want to see for our
community
is the 1980s hiv all over again
where it wasn't talked about it was it
was known that it was out there but
there was no pressure to do anything
about it because oh it's just the gays
it's fine
right you have to believe that if monkey
pox were spreading largely through
heterosexual sex things would be
drastically different by now you'd
probably be able to get a free vax with
purchase at every j crew in the country
because listen it is not homophobic to
acknowledge who is currently most
affected which is gay and bisexual men
sex workers and people who participate
in sex with multiple partners what is
homophobic is when you blame or shame
the people who are suffering or when you
decide you don't need to care about this
because you don't see their lives as
valuable or they're suffering as
consequential and that is where there
are strong echoes of the aids crisis in
some of the discussion around monkey pox
just listen to marjorie taylor green
elected official and one star uber
passenger who dismissed it like this
of course monkey pox is a threat to some
people in our population but we know
what causes it and and that's pretty
much um
it's it's a basically a sexually
transmitted disease uh so it's not a
threat to
to most of the population and so it's
not a global pandemic it's really not
and people just have to have to laugh at
it mock it and and reject it so i think
it's it's another scam
okay obviously that is ridiculous if the
way to get rid of something awful was
for people to laugh at it and mock it
that woman clearly wouldn't be in
congress and yet here we all are
green also tweeted if monkey fox is a
sexually transmitted disease why are
kids getting it in an act of obvious dog
whistle bigotry suggesting gay people
are a danger to children when what's
clearly an actual danger to children is
the q and on congresswoman who once
tweeted the kids at uvalde needed jr15s
and i know there is a temptation when
you see homophobia like that to push
back and say hey it's not just gay
people anyone can get monkey pox which
is true
but it is also true that while anyone
can get it right now certain people are
getting it more and crucially they are
the ones who should be receiving the
lion's share of the resources right now
and specific targeted public health
guidance and the messaging here can
admittedly be a bit of a minefield the
queer community may be understandably
reluctant to hear some straight person
lecturing them about their sex lives
especially when that advice historically
has so often come with an air of
disapproval about it and some in this
current crisis have been tone deaf one
public health official here in new york
pushed for a more abstinence based
approach posting on his website if we
had an outbreak associated with bowling
would we not warn people to stop bowling
which isn't a great way to put it in
fact an openly gay health official
responded by tweeting a white straight
cis man comparing sex to bowling tells
me so much about strange sex which
honestly
that's a fair hit that's a fair hit
right there
the official who wrote that tweet is
actually now the deputy coordinator of
the federal monkey pox response and he's
been talking about this with a
refreshing frankness like in this
official video where he walks through
practical steps to avoid exposure and
then offers this advice to people who
think that they or their partner may
have been exposed
consider the following ways to reduce
the chance of spreading the virus
have virtual sex with no in-person
contact
masturbate together at a distance
without touching each other and without
touching any rash or sores remember to
wash your hands with soap and water and
disinfect fetish gear sex toys and any
fabrics such as bedding towels clothing
after having sex that's great
that is honestly some of the best
communication of public health guidance
i have ever seen it's helpful it's
specific and it's non-judgmental and
honestly it's pretty good advice for
everyone far more people should be
exploring virtual sex with no in-person
contact
just make sure that you're not doing it
in the middle of a work meeting jeffrey
although
that really should not be that hard
and it is not just the government uh
community groups have been trying to
frame health advice in a way that's much
more sex positive making it more likely
to be well received like this flyer from
an la lgbt center with a very practical
tip forget [ __ ] summer hold up for
anal autumn do it inside a donut season
which again
is excellent it's good advice for now
it's good advice for the fall and it's
also a pretty good slogan for duncan
and while
and while good messaging is certainly
welcome here it is depressing that we
have to rely so heavily on it in the
first place given the many systemic
failures that have brought us to this
point so
what can we do now well in the short
term the next six to eight weeks are
going to be crucial so we need to be
ramping up testing and data collection
and getting vaccines and antivirals to
those who need them the most we also
need to make quarantining more
logistically possible for people because
monkey pots can require as long as four
weeks of isolation and for many that is
going to be difficult to manage without
extra support but in the longer term as
if covid had not already made this
abundantly clear we badly need to
restructure our public health system so
it is better able to respond to a viral
outbreak and i'm not the only one saying
that just listen to new york city's
health commissioner it is frustrating we
had a vaccine we have a treatment we had
a test and all of it was kind of rolled
out more slowly than we would have liked
because of the fact that our permanent
public health infrastructure is has not
been invested in for decades yeah he's
right and he is not alone again and
again when we talk to public health
professionals this week there has been a
sense that this was a gigantic [ __ ] up j
varma an epidemiologist who previously
worked at the cdc told us this was a
real perfect stress test for us in this
situation we were uniquely prepared we
kind of had the questions ahead of time
we're going to throw you a virus you
already have a test for already have
vaccine for already have a drug your
government paid for and developed and
discovered and stockpiled let's see how
you respond to that and we screwed it up
which is humiliatingly bad basically on
a scale from 1 to 100 we scored a no
but the thing is even if we do contain
this outbreak and even if we build up
our public health infrastructure there
is a bigger conversation worth having
here because for far too long we've
indulged in the magical thinking that
viruses that exist somewhere else a
don't matter and b will stay there and
monkey pox is such a clear example of
how flawed and racist that thinking is
we had 20 million doses of a vaccine
that could have helped countries in
africa that were known to be high risk
for outbreaks and we didn't help them
and we're still not helping them the
sudden global demand for vaccines means
that currently
zero doses are going to nigeria and
other countries in africa which i know
sounds awful but to be fair indifference
to those suffering from pox viruses has
been the story of america from day one
and i know fixing all of this may feel
daunting but we are living through the
alternative right now and it's not great
and think of it this way if we can
actually get our act together maybe
finally this country and indeed the
whole world can have the anal autumn
that we've all been promised
you